COLT MCANLIS: Ow. [BLEEP] dude.
One of the characteristics
that makes "Compressor Head"
successful, I think, is
really that dynamic range
between the two of us.
Ow. [BLEEP] dude.
Can we try that again?
Do we want to do that one again?
BRIAN GRADY: Sure.
"Compressor Head"
is a universe of knowledge.
COLT MCANLIS: It
was my way of trying
to rekindle a love for this
lost computer science art.
So here's the tricky part
with arithmetic compression.
Why the hell does it work?
Even if you're a PhD
in computer science,
you really aren't taught these
core fundamental algorithms
of compression.
BRIAN GRADY: I never was.
COLT MCANLIS: How would you
teach the most complex thing
possible to a three-year-old?
Well, you wouldn't do
it with a computer,
you wouldn't do
it with a diagram.
You would put blocks and sticky
tape and really bright colors
to show them things
moving in space.
And I said, well, if
that's how I would teach
a three-year-old arithmetic
compression, obviously,
it would work on a programmer.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14.
Huh.
I remember when we pitched
it the first time internally.
We were like, we want
to do this crazy thing
where we talk about compression
and we use Play-Doh.
Oh right.
And just deadpan from
everybody we pitched it to.
They're like, I don't-- why?
We shot a prototype
but we didn't
tell anybody we were
shooting a prototype,
and then we just handed
the video to people,
and it kind of went viral
internally, if you remember.
All of a sudden, my
boss's boss's boss saw it,
and they were like,
yeah, this is great.
We want more.
Then all of a sudden,
overnight, everyone
wanted "Compressor Head."
There's something in this
video series just for you.
It really was
Brian's vision to do
a show that was different
than what we'd done before.
It was the rules of
"Compressor Head."
BRIAN GRADY: You can't walk in
with any props in your hand,
and everything that you use
has to come from the room.
At Google, there's
this place called
the garage that
is made to develop
community and collaboration.
We found out that we
could go into this room.
We could use it like a studio.
There were so many
possibilities.
It had so much junk in it
for us to make things out
of that we could actually
go on set with Colt's ideas
and make stuff that represented
them pretty much in real time
right before we
started shooting.
COLT MCANLIS: Part of the
mania of "Compressor Head"
is literally about the
fact that none of us
know what we're doing until
five minutes beforehand
and the fact that all of us on
the shoot, all of us around it
just have to be OK
with that, literally.
BRIAN GRADY: The lighting
guy doesn't like it.
COLT MCANLIS: The
two ended up creating
the Burrows-Wheeler
transform algorithm.
For me, the magic was
really meeting Mike Burrows
or, as he prefers to be
called on the internet, Mike
[BLEEP] Burrows.
BRIAN GRADY: That's
what he goes by.
COLT MCANLIS: Mike's
the co-inventor
of Burrows-Wheeler transform,
and he works here at Google.
Charming man, but
you talk to him
about the invention of
Burrows-Wheeler transform,
and you realize it should
be the stuff of cinema.
This story is so
amazing and dynamic,
and you're just like, why
does no one know about this?
Why is this not published?
Why is this not on the
Wikipedia page, for god's sake?
Just getting a chance to meet
someone who was a part of that,
I kind of fan boy-ed
out a little bit.
I got red.
One time, he caught
his finger in that.
It was actually pretty funny.
You know what was
number two for me?
BRIAN GRADY: Hm?
COLT MCANLIS: Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah, man.
Let's do it.
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
Ready?
BRIAN GRADY: Magnus.
COLT MCANLIS: The power
of Magnus in that scene.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Aw, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: If you keep up
with the Play Service's What's
New videos, Magnus is
the guy who does them,
and Magnus's energy is just
so higher than any of us
can even get close to.
And then number
three was Joanna.
JOANNA SMITH: I want you
to go and do your job
and tell them exactly how
to succeed with compression.
COLT MCANLIS: Joanna
did a fantastic job.
She really didn't have
to act in that role.
She really does
hate me that much,
and she hates what I do that
much, that it was perfect.
We've got to talk about
the dynamic arithmetic--
JOANNA SMITH: Some of
us have real work to do.
BRIAN GRADY: She has so
little respect for you.
COLT MCANLIS: She does.
So anyway, we're trying a
bunch of different things.
Tell us what you like.
We did season two
because I could not
walk through a conference
without people stopping
me and asking for more.
That's why we do these things
is for developers out there.
And so if the
developers want more
and we hear them
wanting more, we'll
do season three in a heartbeat.
The best thing about working
with Brian that really
humbles me is his patience.
I mean, to have some crazy
bald guy running around, here's
all this crazy stuff, and
iterating back and forth
between you and I
about the movement
in the shot and the direction,
and then someone who actually
has a background in film
actually being patient with all
the craziness that
I bring to the table
and the last minute-ness.
That thing makes
this magic happen.
The mania kind of makes
it magical in that regard,
and Brian's ability to manifest
that and make it happen
is really cool.
BRIAN GRADY: I enjoy
every moment of it.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, it's
the cursing, really, that
brings us together as a team.
BRIAN GRADY: The dirty talk.
If I was going to work
with one of the guys here,
this would be the guy that would
go do something crazy with me,
and I wanted to do
something crazy.
He is known to make everybody
a little bit better than they
were, and I feel like that's
happened to me as well.
I've learned more about
compression than I ever
thought I'd want to.
It's really the most fun
I think I've had at work.
COLT MCANLIS: We get it done.
BRIAN GRADY: We get it done.
COLT MCANLIS: Fist bump.
Boom.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
this is "Compressor Head."